[Música]
inició en Lima Perú la asamblea de la
oea número 52 donde discutirán temas
como la desigualdad y la discriminación
otras las preocupaciones también
regionales giraron alrededor de la
crisis que atraviesan países como
Nicaragua y Haití como lo estábamos
hablando con esa cronista de salud más
Romero sala sin embargo Cumbres como
estas cada vez más pierden más peso en
la comunidad internacional vamos a
analizar el Por qué con Guillermo cochés
ex embajador de Panamá en la oea el año
2009-2013 ex embajador Gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo América de
Francia 24 empezamos hablando de la
importancia de un organismo como este
como la oea la Organización de Estados
Americanos
bueno Buenos días y muchas gracias por
la invitación Yo creo que la oea como
las Naciones Unidas a nivel global la
oea a nivel regional es importante
Simplemente porque traza los límites de
la convivencia hemisférica que hoy se
vendan afectados por situaciones como la
de Nicaragua la de Venezuela
la y aquella generada por los migrantes
en en la frontera de Colombia y Panamá
por eso es importante
la existencia de un organismo como la
oea
ex embajador Le quiero preguntar digamos
que se discute en Noé a las decisiones
que ahí se tomen son determinantes para
un país digamos que esté amenazado que
necesita ayuda o un país donde la
comunidad internacional pues lo castigue
como el caso de Venezuela por las
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos como
el caso de Nicaragua también Que
realmente pasa en el seno de loea para
estos países no
definitivamente que la organización
carece de elementos coercitivos para
hacer cumplir sus decisiones es la la
instancia de la oea la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos la
que determina por ejemplo la situación
de violación de estos derechos en países
como
Venezuela o en Ecuador durante Rafael
Correa cuando
violentaba la libertad de prensa sin
embargo son los países los que deben
aceptar y acatar las normas que dictan y
los preceptos que dictan
estos organismos de protección de
Derechos Humanos por eso es que estos
países en lugar de acatarlos denuncian a
la oea de persecución y que sirve a los
Estados Unidos cuando eso es totalmente
falso la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos es totalmente
independiente y vigila por el
cumplimiento de los Derechos Humanos en
todo el continente recordamos que en
términos en términos de Derechos Humanos
no hay fronteras o sea yo no puedo decir
que yo hago en mi país lo que me da la
gana no hay reglas de convivencia que
hay que cumplir sin embargo estos países
para no cumplirlas y evadirlas casos de
Nicaragua caso Venezuela optan por
denunciar la carta de la oea y salirse
de la organización como ha ocurrido con
estos dos países y digamos que la
comunidad internacional ya no no se
puede meter en los asuntos internos de
un país así hayan esas violaciones de
Derechos Humanos como usted lo dijo se
lo digo porque también
cosas últimamente se han cargado contra
la Organización de Estados Americanos y
también contra la ONU diciendo que estos
organismos pierden cada vez más fuerza
digamos que lo que se habla ahí al final
no no no no no lo respetan los otros
países como lo estaba hablando también
usted
bueno esto esto que está ocurriendo
ahora mismo con la oea no es nuevo
cuando yo estuve en la organización en
el 2009 2000 a 2013 ocurría algo
parecido países como Venezuela que
tenían informes de violación de Derechos
Humanos que tenían acusaciones de
intromisión en los asuntos internos de
Colombia al permitir que la guerrilla se
asentase en territorio venezolano para
atacar a Colombia eso motivó el
rompimiento de Chávez con Uribe
simplemente querían ignorar la realidad
y por eso atacaban a la oea igual
ocurrió con Rafael Correa que denunció a
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos Por el simple hecho de estar
diciéndole usted no puede seguir
violando los derechos de los periodistas
y de la libertad de expresión en en en
Ecuador
eso es lo que ocurre O sea no es nuevo
es una hora de los protestantes contra
la oea porque los llaman la atención son
países que quieren estar por encima de
la ley como hoy vemos estado ocurriendo
en Nicaragua
en su opiniones embajador que se puede
hacer para fortalecer organismos como
los Estados Americanos como el ejercicio
de los Estados Americanos las bases no
para poder tener una oea más
operante es necesario afianzar los
sistemas democráticos de cada uno de
nuestros países
Nicaragua por ejemplo es un ejemplo de
la violación de esos derechos
democráticos cuando vino la última
elección el el presidente Ortega decidió
encarcelar a todos los candidatos que
pudieran oponersele claro Él gana las
elecciones las gana entre comillas
democráticamente entre comillas
y nadie le puede llamar la atención
Igual pasa en Venezuela donde no hay
libertades ni partidos políticos la
gente está exiliada persiguen a los
opositores hay muchos Defensores de
Derechos Humanos detenidos Entonces no
hay manera de que puede haber un sistema
democrático confiable por eso es que
para poder tener una oea práctica y
operante requerimos de fortalecer los
sistemas democráticos de cada uno de
nuestros países que desafortunadamente
cada vez están más débiles y el diálogo
con estos países no pudiera ser también
una forma de fortalecer organizaciones
como la como la oea lo digo también por
lo que vimos en la Cumbre de las
Américas en Los Ángeles cuando se
decidió no invitar a los gobiernos de de
Venezuela de Nicaragua por ejemplo
también entonces el presidente López
Obrador dijo que no iba a ir por lo que
estaba ocurriendo Cómo se puede hacer
para realmente de las Américas
independientemente de los gobiernos que
hayan porque al final también lo que los
los que sufren son la población los los
propios ciudadanos entendiendo los
problemas evidentemente de democracia y
Derechos Humanos que puedan tener
deberíamos Buscar como también una una
solución O para poder trabajar con esas
personas y que no se sigan violando y se
siga agravando la situación de esos
países
mire en el 2009 en la yo estaba en esa
asamblea en San Pedro Sula Honduras se
decidió invitar nuevamente a uno al
único país que había sido suspendido de
la oea me refiero a Cuba sí Cuba fue re
admitida en la oea pero para que Cuba
pueda entrar en la oea tiene que aceptar
los principios básicos de democracia
establecidos en la carta democrática Ese
es el gran problema que quieren
participar pero sin ser demócratas Y si
eso lo permitimos Imagínate lo que
pasaría con el resto de los países qué
ejemplo estaríamos dando igual ocurriría
en la Unión Europea y por eso ahí los
controles que existen con países que
están al borde de no tener un sistema
democrático y le son llamados la
atención y ahí mecanismos para
presionarlos para que cumplan con Esas
reglas desafortunadamente los mecanismos
existentes en América son bastante
débiles y y loco como tú lo dices los
que sufren son los pobladores de esos
países casos por ejemplo de Nicaragua
que hoy en día está aislada del sistema
de beneficios del banco interamericano
de desarrollo y de otras entidades
multilaterales porque simplemente no
está cumpliendo con los procesos
democráticos que exigen estos organismos
a todos sus miembros